"Північний потік-2", як і його попередник,
прокладається для того, щоб припинити транзит
російського газу через територію України.
Головні загрози для Києва - це занепад газотранспортної
системи та енергетична ізоляція України.
Ось тут, на балтійському узбережі Німеччини
поблизу міста Грайфсвальд - по сусідству
з "Північним потоком" - і буде побудований
термінал для "Північного потоку-2".
Однак це лише перший етап.
Склалася абсолютно помилкова точка зору, що
досить побудувати "Північний потік-2" і він одразу ж
почне працювати на повну силу.
Але замало лише дотягнути дві нитки до узбережжя Німеччини.
Потрібно ще побудувати продовження цих
двох ниток по території Німеччини.
Такі плани є. Це труба, точніше дві труби EUGAL
будуть побудовані. Але за планом лише до кінця 2020 року.
EUGAL - абревіатура, вона розшифровується
як Європейський з'єднувальний газопровід.
Проектна протяжність майже 500 кілометрів,
він має пройти від Балтійського моря до кордону з Чехією.
Загальна потужність двох його ниток складе понад
50 мільярдів кубометрів газу на рік.
Прокладати його збирається компанія Gascade
зі штаб-квартирою в Касселі.
Наше завдання - займатися транспортуванням газу,
в тому числі, мабуть, і того, що буде надходити
по "Північному потоку-2", але не тільки.
Ми споруджуємо газопровід, який здатний
транспортувати газ з різних джерел, причому в
усіх напрямках, оскільки він буде інтегрований
в існуючу трудопровідну інфраструктуру.
Варто відзначити, що компанія Gascade, яка
наполовину належить Газпрому,  всіляко намагається
не афішувати свій зв'язок з російським концерном.
Тобто EUGAL позиціонується не як частина
газпромівського проекту "Північний потік-2",
а як європейський проект, як європейський газопровід,
який покликаний доповнити газову інфраструктуру
в Європейському союзі.
Цей трубопровід вважається загальнодоступним.
Однак насправді це не так. Газпром заздалегідь і на
відкритому аукціоні забронював усі його потужності.
Але така стратегія для газового гіганта
може бути вельми ризикованою.
Адже якщо "Північний потік-2" забуксує, а EUGAL
буде, навпаки, запущений, то Газпрому доведеться
платити повну ціну за порожню трубу.
Клієнт зобов'язаний оплачувати законтрактовані газотранспортні потужності.
Використовуються вони при цьому чи ні,
для нас питання другорядне.
У 2016 році екс-канцлер Німеччини Ґергард Шредер
очолив раду директорів компанії Nord Stream 2 -
оператора проекту газопроводу.
У зв'язку з цим він активно лобіює новий проект і
запевняє, що будівництво нової труби не має
нічого спільного з геополітикою.
Нам потрібен цей газ.  І це найдешевший варіант,
який тільки може бути. І кожен, хто
займається енергетикою, знає це.
При цьому політик відкидає критику, що Росія
і Німеччина будують нову трубу на шкоду інтересам інших країн.
Звичайно, як в країнах Балтії, так і в Польщі
є побоювання, які історично виправдані.
Але не можна тільки ними керуватися, адже ці
країни члени НАТО та ЄС, і їм забезпечена вся необхідна безпека.
Втім, нинішнє керівництво ФРН подало чіткий сигнал.
За словами виконуючого обов'язки глави МЗС
Німеччини Зіґмара Ґабріеля, "Північний потік-2"
буде реалізований тільки за умови
збереження українського маршруту.
Інакше Берлін може приєднатися до противників газпромівського проекту.